if you're shocked that cnn is going
after joe biden well then you're really
gonna i mean my god you're gonna freak
out right now because the mental
institution known as msnbc which they
televised 24 hours a day a 24 hour a day
mental institution
they're going after him too here's joe
scarborough uh and steve ratner and
they're not happy with joe biden anymore
exactly what happens and my god i just
wonder what would have happened if
progressives have gotten their six
trillion dollar wish earlier this year
yeah in an ironic way you almost have to
thank joe manchin for blocking that
because six and a half trillion dollars
of spending in this economy would make
these numbers look small yeah look we
had a we had a huge budget deficit we
had an unbelievably aggressive reaction
by the fed to the pandemic you can kind
of understand why they were trying but
they just tried too hard and now we're
all going to pay the consequences in a
very very tough environment over the
next year or two while this gets sorted
out
and by the way i wouldn't even say
ironically thank joe manchin you can
just thank joe manchin
uh if you're glad that interest rates
aren't even higher
for the life of me
i can't figure out why they keep doing
this uh
you know going to the press setting
false deadlines
deadlines that are going to fail this is
pretty simple stuff let me say that
again
this is pretty simple stuff
you get the head of the progressive
caucus
you get
joe mansion
and you get
joe biden
and you put him in a room
and you say we're not going to get out
of this room until one of two things
happen
one we have a deal
or two
we're gonna have a press conference
where we go out and announce that joe
mansion does not support any piece of
legislation regarding build back better
senator manchin has said that he would
support universal pre-k full
1.75
trillion dollars that would be an
extraordinary new
uh entitlement for american families
if that's the case
you don't find that out by talking to
reporters or setting deadlines
you get in the room and not with a
thousand people
get mansion
get the head of the progressive caucus
get joe biden sit at a table
and do it like you have done it like
every other business person has done it
for years and say okay let's make a deal
oh let's just walk away from this
take i mean if you take mansion at his
word
he's already committed he shook biden's
hand he said i'll give you 1.75 trillion
so you start by saying joe
show us your bill
not what you might support show us your
bill
and let's see where we go from there and
then walk out make the announcement he
we either have a bill or joe manchin
will never support anything and he's
been lying to us for the past year and a
half it's very clear i don't think joe
has been lying i just think they keep
talking around him and they're talking
to their constituents and they're
talking to other people in the house and
they're talking to other people in the
senate instead of talking to the guy
that's going to give them the 49th and
50th vote okay so this is wild and i
want to say i like when people who are
wrong about everything get things right
right that's why i'm always going on
about bill maher it's like you're wrong
about a lot of stuff then you get some
stuff right i want to get you there okay
don lemon you're wrong about everything
occasionally you're right i want to get
you there joe scarborough you're wrong
about everything you're right about
something occasionally i want to get you
there what's incredible about this is
msnbc everyone on msnbc everybody i'm
sure in those 87 boxes they just showed
you an iq combined of six these people
all of course push for the american
rescue plan which led to this
it led to this take a pen one starting
point one ending point
it gets us there okay you can't just
print money and then think nothing's
gonna happen